>>Female Presenter: Hi everyone.
My name is Erica Chung and I work in People
Operations and I also work on the @Google
Talks team in New York.
And today, it is my great, great pleasure
to introduce Kristi Yamaguchi to Google [phone
rings in background].
Kristi, I think you guys all know, but she
is the 1992 Olympic figure skater Champion.
She's also a winner of a recent season of
"Dancing With the Stars" and she had recently
added best-selling author to her litany of
accomplishments.
[giggles] And her book is called "Dream Big,
Little Pig."
So, we're gonna ask her to actually do a reading
for us today.
Kristi's also--on a personal note--my childhood
hero.
So I am absolutely thrilled.
[audience laughs] I can't tell you how excited
I am to be sitting here right now.
So, Kristi, I thought we would just start
by talking a little bit about figure skating
and your journey.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: OK.
>>Female Presenter: And I understand that--correct
me if I'm wrong--but I believe you had started
skating as a form of therapy to correct clubbed
feet.
Is that true?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Well, it did help with
strength and coordination.
I was born with club feet and was in casts
for the first year or so of my life.
And then corrective shoes and braces until
maybe two.
I remember learning to walk with the brace
in-between my feet [chuckles].
But those corrections were pretty much done
early on.
And when I started to do different activities,
like ballet and wanted to try skating, my
mom asked the pediatrician if it was OK, if
it was an OK activity.
And I think he thought it was wonderful because
it would just help with the coordination and
everything.
And I'm lucky that my parents took the initiative
and had the corrections done early on.
And it didn't seem to affect my skating.
[laughs]
>>Female Presenter: Was it your choice to
begin skating, or was that something your
parents came up with?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: It was definitely my choice.
>>Female Presenter: OK.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: I had seen a local ice
show and remembered Dorothy Hamill had just
won the Olympics a few years earlier, so she
was my childhood idol.
And I just wanted to try skating as well.
So, my older sister, Lori, actually started
skating for a couple of months, but she didn't
really like it.
But being my older sister, I still wanted
to try it and just loved it the very first
time.
>>Female Presenter: OK.
And did you, at what point did this drive
to actually keep competing and to pursue going
to Regionals and Nationals and Sectionals
and all of that, when did that kick in?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Well, everything just
snowballed.
I mean, you start out once a week going to
group classes.
And I was having fun.
And then, I think maybe a year or so after
I started skating, taking part in my first
competition that was just rink-wide and coming
11th out of 12th, wasn't what I was hoping
for.
[laughs]
So, I think that stoked the fire . Like, "Well,
how come I didn't get a medal?"
And my mom's like, "Well, you have to be in
the top three to get a medal."
So, I think at that point I was like, "I want
a medal.
[giggles] [audience laughs]Every time I go
out there I wanna win a medal."
And I think that resonated with me and it's
like, "OK, I need to improve."
And when I'm competing, you have other competitors
that you're being compared to or whatever.
So, I don't know.
I think I just loved the skating so much and
competition, which was part of it.
And pretty soon, you're competing in your
Northern California area.
And then I was competing for the West Coast.
So, it just grew from liking the ice shows.
[giggles]
>>Female Presenter: You actually started--.
Did you start off as a single skater?
You were actually competing pretty, on the
National level, as a pair skater as well.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: I did compete in both.
I started skating when I was six, so I skated
individual until I was eleven years old.
And then that's when I met my partner, Rudy
Galindo.
He was 13 at the time.
He had just won the Novice National Championships
in singles.
And I think people were going, "Oh, you're
both so tiny and cute.
You should skate pairs together."
[laughter]
So I said, "OK.
It sounds like fun."
So, we did it for fun, really.
And our pair coach just taught us what he
could and we went to competitions.
And before we knew it, we were at National
Championships in Novice Pairs.
And then we won Junior Pairs, maybe I think
four years into our partnership together.
So, we were having some great success.
And I think because we were both strong single
skaters and coming together, but we had fun.
We went as far as two-time US Pair Champions.
>>Female Presenter: At the senior level.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: At the senior level.
Went to World's and we were fifth at the World
Championships two years in a row.
And so, I think success came early and fast
for us as a pair team.
And then at the same time, I continued on
with my singles career.
So, keeping, developing there as well.
But I think at the time, we were competing
against, in the pairs category, the top Russian,
the top Czechoslovakian and Canadian teams.
So, for us to be fifth two years in a row
was really I think as far as we thought we
could go.
And it was time to make a decision either
way 'cause juggling both disciplines was getting
more difficult at that World level.
And it was a tough decision, but I knew I
would always go back to, or continue on with
the singles skating.
So, that's where I turned my focus.
>>Female Presenter: During that time when
you had to make that decision, did you ever,
what was that process like?
And did you ever second guess that?
Or, I mean, I think now looking back, you
guys have both individually and as pairs partners,
achieved so much.
I mean, Rudy went on to win the National title
as well.
But looking forward, you couldn't have known
that.
And so, what was that like for you?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: It was tough because we
had grown up together, literally, from eleven
to 17, 18 years old.
And so, making that decision--.
We had just imagined careers the rest of our
lives together.
But things change and your goals change.
So, it was just time to make a decision.
So, it was tough for a few months and I made
the decision and tried to be as positive as
I could.
And I don't think it was as easy on Rudy.
I think he was hoping that we would continue
on, but I was determined to continue to skate
and had, like you said, had some great success
as well, winning Nationals and then becoming
bronze medalist in the world.
So, I think looking back it was a good decision
for both of us.
[giggles]
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
I think so.
What were the Olympics like for you?
What was that?
Can you tell us a little bit about that experience?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Absolutely.
Olympic year was just a whirlwind.
And I think my goal was just to make the Olympic
team.
The year before, I had won World's and it
wasn't really until a year before the Olympics
where I thought, "Wow.
I actually have a shot at making the Olympic
team.
Now I can let myself believe that I can actually
be there."
So, at the US National Championships, I went
in.
I had never won a national title ever in singles.
I had already won two pair titles--actually,
three 'cause we won juniors--but I had never
won singles.
I was always second in every level coming
up.
So, I actually won my first national title.
And so, that just gave me a lot of confidence
going into the Olympics the next month.
And I was just so honored to be named to the
team.
I think once I was there, it was like, "Well,
I'm here now.
Whatever happens happens.
[presenter giggles] Of course, I want to skate
my best and skate well because I've trained
so hard to get here."
But the gold medal was something I didn't
wanna think about.
I don't know.
I didn't wanna jinx myself.
But I knew if I skated as well as I could,
I would have a good shot at it.
>>Female Presenter: So, I was actually listening
to a talk recently by an author named Joshua
Foer and he wrote a book called "Moonwalking
with Einstein."
And so in this talk he was talking about just
the importance of stepping outside of your
comfort zone.
He actually used figure skating as an example.
So, what he said was the best figure skaters
actually spend more time falling than they
do practicing the jumps that they know that
they can land.
Did you find that to be your case in your
situation?
'Cause I know when I was skating,
I'm like, "OK, let's stick to my axel.
Coast on my axel for a while before moving
on to my double "sal"."
And it's probably why I didn't go to the Olympics,
[giggles] but did you find that to be the
case?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Yeah, definitely.
I think coming up as a skater, you know in
order to get to the next level or learn that
next jump or spin or whatever, you're gonna
make a lot of mistakes.
So, definitely.
I remember working on by double axel, which
is a big step--.
It's the hardest double to learn.
And just saying, "OK, I'm gonna work 20 minutes
on my double axel."
And it would just be literally skate around,
jump, fall, skate around, jump, fall, skate
around--.
[giggles]
For 20 minutes.
And you're just waiting for that moment for
it to click.
And I think my coaches at the time were just
very good at instilling in me, "OK, you just,
this is just what you have to do."
[chuckles] And because you look around and
you see other people doing it and are landing
the jump that it motivates you to keep doing
it and finally get it.
So, I think ultimately, finally, she offered
like a hundred dollars [laughter] if I could
land it clean.
And that ramped up the practice a little more.
>>Female Presenter: And then how long did
it take you for it to click after that?
[laughing]
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Like a week.
[giggles]
[laughter]
So, yeah.
I mean, in skating, it's all about falling.
And the first thing we learn as skaters stepping
onto the ice is how to get up when you fall
because it's gonna happen.
[giggles]
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
So, I thought we'd switch gears a little bit
and talk about your book.
What led you to wanting to write a book?
And how did you come up with this idea?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: I think--.
I worked with children quite a bit.
I've had a foundation for 15 years that has
centered on the needs of children for us,
so I've always wanted to do a children's book.
But it was never, I guess, in the forefront
of my priorities.
But I think, my own two children, becoming
a mother, really inspired me.
When I started working on the book, they were
four and six, so perfectly in that age range
that I wanted to target.
And I thought it would be just something special
for them to have that Mom wrote a book for
them.
[audience laughs lightly]
So, I didn't know where to start, but luckily
I had a book agent who approached me and said
that she would help me and got involved in
the process right away.
And luckily found a publisher in Sourcebooks
that came along and said, "OK, we like your
story.
Let's move with it."
So it was really a labor of love and I didn't
know what would happen with it.
Of course, always hoping that the story would
grasp and take root and resonate with the
audience.
And I guess the concept for the book came
as, well, if I'm gonna do this, looking at
some of my favorite books or children's books,
they all have some type of message.
And I wanted a positive message to leave with
the kids and something, possibly, that I had
learned through skating to pass on to them.
So, that's where the concept of the book came
about from.
>>Female Presenter: OK.
So, we have, actually, a couple kids in the
audience here.
I believe some Googlers brought their kids.
[giggles] Did you wanna do a little bit of
book reading for us?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Yes.
Sure.
Definitely.
All right.
So, it's called "Dream Big, Little Pig," and
illustrated by Tim Bowers.
>>Female Presenter: All right.
[children talking]
[Kristi Yamaguchi reads from book]
"Poppy was a pig--a pot-bellied, waddling,
toddling pig.
She was a pig with dreams and she was a pig
who dreamed big.
She wanted to be a star.
Poppy had always dreamed of being a posh prima
ballerina.
“She tried out for Swan Lake, a famous ballet,
but Poppy was not graceful.
In fact, she was quite clumsy.
'Follow your dreams!' said Poppy's mother,
who loved her no matter what.
'You go, Girl!' said Poppy's grandparents,
who were her biggest fans.
'Dream big, Pig!' said Poppy's best friend
Emma, who was always there for her.
'Dancing is just not for you,' said the people
in charge of the ballet.
“'Try something else.'
So, Poppy tried out for Singing Stars, a popular
chorus competition.
She'd always dreamed of being a soulful singer.
But Poppy sang off-key.
And to be honest, she couldn't really carry
a tune."
>>Child: Look at Poppy!
[laughter]
"'Follow your dreams!' said Poppy's mother.
‘You go, Girl!' said Poppy's grandparents.
‘Dream big, Pig!' said Emma.
‘Singing is just not for you,' said the
people in charge of the competition.
‘Try something else.'
“So, Poppy tried out for Supermodel Search.
[audience chuckles] She had always dreamed
of being a big time, splashy supermodel.
But Poppy was not very glitzy or glittery.
And she even tripped on her fancy gown.
'Follow your dreams!' said Poppy's mother.
'You go, Girl!' said Poppy's grandparents.
“'Dream big, Pig!' said Emma.
'Modeling is just not for you,' said the people
in charge of the search.
'Try something else.'
But Poppy didn't know what else to try.
And as she wandered through New Pork City,
she began to wonder if her dreams would really
come true.
“Poppy was about to give up when she heard
her mother say, 'Just follow your heart.
Remember, we love you no matter what.'
And her grandparents cheer, 'We're your biggest
fans!'
And her best friend Emma's squeal, 'We're
here for you!'
Poppy smiled.
“She knew just what to do.
When Poppy thought about all the things she
truly loved, her friends and family were at
the top of her list.
So the next day, Poppy invited Emma for a
Pig's Day Out in the park.
While giggling and strolling along, they spotted
an ice rink.
Poppy and Emma watched the skaters skimming
and spinning, swooping and swizzling on the
ice.
“Poppy realized that it was the most beautiful
sight that she had ever seen.
Her heart danced with joy.
Emma saw a twinkle in Poppy's eye and high-fived
her friend.
'Dream big, Pig!' she cheered.
So Poppy waddled and toddled right up to the
skating teacher and said, 'I'd like to be
a spectacular ice skating star.'
“'A pig on ice,' the teacher pondered.
'Honey, I don't know if that's possible.'
'Anything's possible,' said Poppy.
'I believe in dreaming big.'
The teacher shrugged.
'As you wish,' she said.
'We'll see if the pig's got pizazz.'
Poppy laced up her skates.
She slipped and slid all over the ice.
“And she fell.
But this time, Poppy got up over and over
and over.
She shuffled and stumbled and fumbled and
fell.
But by the time the rink closed for the night,
Poppy was skating more than she was falling.
And it felt like magic.
Poppy returned to the rink the very next day.
“Her cheeks were pink with winter wind and
excitement.
She was so happy gliding, sliding, and tumbling
and bumbling on the ice.
She didn't even notice that she wasn't perfect.
And nobody else did, either.
Now a most persistent pig, Poppy learned to
twirl and swirl and do dips and lunges and
splits.
Poppy learned to do jumps and spirals and
lifts.
“Before she knew it, more and more skaters
stopped to watch Poppy practice.
She was quite a sight.
She even had her picture on the front page
of the newspaper.
Poppy felt like a star.
Some of her fans made t-shirts that read,
'Follow your dreams.'
Other wore hats that said, 'Dream big, Pig!'
And tote bags declared, 'You go, Girl!'
Poppy's dreams had come true.
“Time went by, but Poppy didn't stop dreaming.
One day, she decided to be a pilot.
She wanted to parachute and be the first sky-diving
pig.
'When pigs fly,' said the other pilots.
But they did not know Poppy.
She was a pig who dreamed big.
The end."
[applause]
Thank you.
Thanks.
So, this is a fun little story about a little
pig who kept trying and finally found her
passion.
So, I thought it was a good thing for kids
and adults to keep dreaming.
You can never dream too big.
>>Female Presenter: Have your daughters actually
started skating?
I know between you and your husband, you're
both spectacular on the ice.
Have they taken to skating at all?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: They like to go out and
skate with their friends.
We'll get on the ice with them every now and
then, but they run away from us because they
don't like Mommy telling them what to do.
[laughter]
So it's almost better they take lessons from
someone else.
And they're just beginning.
They're in group classes.
So as long as they can skate and move around
on the ice, that's all we care about.
We don't expect them to do shows or compete
or anything.
But you have to know how to skate in our family.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: And have you, do you still
skate pretty regularly?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Well, unfortunately, I
haven't really been skating much lately.
I think my last performance was almost two
years ago.
So, it's, my priority now is my family and
keeping up with the girl's schedules.
But we're still involved with skating a little
bit.
I'm part of the US Figure Skating Mentoring
program, where some of their past skaters
are mentoring the younger skaters coming up.
And then also, hosting a couple of the television
shows that are broadcast on NBC.
So, a little bit here and there.
But I miss it on the ice a little bit.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
And I mean, just listening to you read the
book, I mean it sounds like Poppy went through
a couple different things before stumbling
across skating.
And how important do you think is raw talent?
I guess just sheer determination in pursuing
something that you're interested in and ultimately
succeeding at?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: I think it's--.
My grandmother always said, "You have to have
the three D's.
Determination, Dedication, and Desire."
And if you don't have those, then you're not
gonna have success.
And I completely believe that because I was
not the most talented.
My mom would always say, "Well, they're learning
it much faster than you.
And why can't you do that?
[laughs] They're already doing that."
And she knew.
She's like, "Well, I think you just need to
work a little harder in order to progress
like the other kids."
And I think that was good.
It taught me a work ethic and I wasn't afraid
to work and was willing to in order to learn
something new.
So, I've seen a lot of talented skaters come
up really quickly and when it got tough, they
seemed to fizzle out.
And I think you have to be willing to put
in that extra amount of work--stay on the
ice an extra few minutes in order to separate
yourself from the rest.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
And I think we do have a lot of parents in
the audience right now.
Do you have any advice for the parents here
as to how to encourage their children to be
physically active?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Well, like all parents,
I'm still learning along the way, too.
Mine are just five and seven now.
But I think both my husband and I were so
involved with sports our entire lives and
knowing that being involved in sports taught
us a lot of things.
I think it gave us a lot of confidence.
It taught us how to respect ourselves, our
competitors, our own bodies.
So, I think those are all important things
that kids can learn through sports.
And something that we're trying to encourage
our own children to get involved in because
teamwork and being part of that.
And there's so many great lessons to be learned
that I think to encourage them, it's hard
to keep pushing.
But I think trying to help them find maybe
what their passion is and then supporting
it once they do find it.
>>Female Presenter: And you also--.
Going along this theme of dreams, you also
run the Always Dream Foundation.
And you've been involved with this for, was
it 15 years?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Yeah.
Actually, almost 16 now, yeah.
>>Female Presenter: Sixteen years.
So, can you tell us a little bit about that
and the work that you do through your foundation?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Sure.
It's Always Dream.
We've, or I, established it because I was
inspired by the Make A Wish Foundation, which
does a lot of work with children and their
families.
So, I decided to create something that will
help touch the lives of children out there
and in all genres.
We've helped children with disabilities, to
disadvantaged children, under-served children,
children of tragedies like Hurricane Katrina
and the recent tsunami in Japan.
So, we've dedicated ourselves to embrace the
hopes and dreams of children in whatever way
we can.
Now we are turning our focus more on education,
again, inspired by my children entering public
school.
So, we really wanna try to help the literacy
component and really target early childhood
literacy and technology and finding a way
to combine those two and make a difference,
because we know that reading levels--and especially
at the 3rd Grade level--will help determine
your success in not only school, but in life
as well.
So, if we can make a difference there, especially
in the under-served areas where these children
don't have access to books, and we want to
teach them to learn to love reading and to
love books as early on as possible.
>>Female Presenter: OK.
I thought we could take some time to open
it up to the floor for questions.
>>FEMALE #1: Hi, Kristi.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Hi there.
>>FEMALE #1: Thank you for coming to Google
today.
It's so nice to meet you.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Thank you.
>>FEMALE #1: I'm wondering if you got nervous
before you competed and what you did to try
to control that.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: OK.
Can you hear me still?
Is this still on?
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
OK.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Definitely got nervous
every time I competed, even for every show,
almost every performance.
But I think just a lot of positive reinforcement.
The night before the competition,
I did a lot of imagery and walking through
what I wanted to do and going through the
entire routine, making sure it's perfect.
[giggles] If it wasn't, I'd go back and rewind
and do it until it was how I wanted and then
I could fall asleep.
But especially, right before stepping on the
ice, there's a lot of anxiety and it was just
common breathing techniques as well as telling
myself, "I've trained for this.
I'm ready."
I think the training that I did leading into
the competitions always was something I leaned
back on.
And I said, "I've done this a hundred times
at home, at my rink, in the comfort of my
surroundings there."
I just wanted to take myself back to my training
rink and just tell myself it's just like any
other day.
"Just go out and do what you can."
But I think just preparation and the training
helped with the confidence.
[pause]
Oh, I see a question here.
>>Female Presenter: I think we have a question
over there.
>>FEMALE #2: Hi Kristi, it's nice to meet
you.
Thank you very much for coming to Google.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Sure.
>>FEMALE #2: First of all, I just wanna tell
you that, like Erica said, you've been one
of my idols growing up.
There are very few strong Asian American women
in the media to look up to.
So, thank you for being here and sharing your
story.
And another question I have is I know that
you grew up in the Bay Area, specifically
Fremont, which is where I also grew up.
So, I'd like to hear about how growing up
in the Bay Area in Fremont has influenced
you.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Yeah.
I feel like just any other California girl
I guess out there.
I mean, Fremont was a great place to grow
up in.
I remember it being very diverse and just
a great place.
I think being in the Bay Area in general,
I think you have access to so much right at
your fingertips.
And I don't know.
I think my parents were great to support whatever
it was I dreamed of.
[giggles] People ask, there's been Peggy Fleming,
Brian Boitano, Debbie Thomas, obviously Rudy
Galindo, and Charlie Tickner, and we're all
from the Bay Area.
And it's like the Bay Area has produced some
very successful skaters.
But yet, we've all had different coaches.
We've all trained at different rinks.
So, we kinda don't know why.
I mean, I think we--.
Skating's popular here and we have a great
set of rinks, but maybe we just have a bigger
pool of talent to pull from.
But I can't explain that, but I think it is
a great place as far as nurturing sports and
being open and allowing different--.
Skating's probably not the number one sport
to go into, but there's still places to train
and focus on it.
>>FEMALE #2: Thank you.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: I want this energy.
[laughter]
>>FEMALE #3: Hi Kristi.
It's good to meet you.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Hello.
>>FEMALE #3: I also grew up in Fremont, by
the way.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Oh, all right.
>>FEMALE #3: I just wanted to ask, after you
achieved your amazing success at the Olympics
and such, did you ever have moments after
that saying, "How can I top this?
What do I do next?
Where do I go from here?"
Did you ever feel lost at all?
Or, you hadn't actually thought past that
point or anything like that?
And how did you come to where you are now?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: I probably have thoughts
like that more now than I did after the Olympics.
I think I was really fortunate that in skating,
I was able to look beyond the Olympics and
see a career path ahead.
Back in 1992, there was a very rich professional
skating atmosphere to join, so I knew if I
didn't continue to compete,
I wanted to tour as a professional.
And that was really my ultimate dream.
When I was little, it wasn't really the Olympics.
I didn't know what that was.
It was to be a professional skater touring
the world.
So, I knew I wanted to do that for several
years after the Olympics.
But there were times when like, "Is that like
the highlight of my life?
How sad at 20 I peaked?
What does gonna happen now?"
[laughter]
But I think using that fear and then finding
other challenges to face kept me going.
And dedicating myself to a ten-year professional
career was one, and then looking beyond that,
I knew family was another that the timing
was just right.
And then, once my kids were older and I felt,
"OK, I have time now to maybe do some other
things," then that's when Dancing With the
Stars came about and other projects.
So, I don't know.
I think I feel the most alive and the most
energy when I have something to look forward
to and a new challenge in front of me.
>>FEMALE #3: Thank you.
>>Male Helper: So Erica, we might need to
take some VC questions .
>>Female Presenter: Oh, hello?
>>FEMALE #4: Hi Kristi.
Thank you for coming.
I actually met you.
This is the second time I'm watching you talk.
The first time I saw you talk was back in
Iceoplex.
And this was when I was in 7th Grade.
You kinda showed up, in Logitech Skating or
something in Fremont off of Warm Springs.
But I remember being in 7th Grade and seeing
you there and I was just so ecstatic.
So, I'm glad to see you again.
I had a quick question for you because I used
to skate.
I mean, nothing really crazy or anything,
but the highest jump I could do was a double
loop.
And so, I haven't skated in a really, really,
really long time and I'm afraid to back because
I just don't wanna be disappointed to not
be able to do anything except skate around
in a circle.
[laughter]
So, I wanted to see how you feel about going
back to skating 'cause you said you haven't
skated, or your last show was two years ago.
And also, how do you feel if you can't do
a certain jump that you used to could do like,
with your eyes closed?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: I feel your pain, for
sure.
[audience chuckles] I think my first experience
with that was taking a break for the birth
of our first daughter.
I had never been off the ice for more than
probably three, four weeks or something.
So, after she was born, I knew I wanted--.
I had a little bit more skating left in me
and so, it was just getting back on the ice
and getting back in shape slowly.
But now, it's been a couple years since I've
really skated skated.
I mean, my best advice would be to start off
ice training a little bit first.
I think just preparing the body to get on
the ice, because otherwise you'll just be
really frustrated I think.
[giggles] So, I think Pilates and all of that,
yoga, any type of cardio you can do off the
ice will help your body get prepared to go
on the ice.
Because once you put the skates on, you wanna
be able to skate around and not--, and have
the strength to do that and the stamina to
do that.
>>FEMALE #4: Yeah.
I remember before, I had no problems like
launching myself into the air and falling.
It was kinda fun, but now the thought of that
is just scary and I can't do it.
[giggles]
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Yeah, I think the older
you get, those pain receptors seem to become
more sensitive.
[giggles]So, it's, yeah.
I tend to--.
It's hard.
I know I can't do the jumps that I used to
and that's frustrating.
And my focus isn't on the training anymore,
so I know and I have to be realistic that
I'm not doing that anymore.
But that's a big part of the reason why I'm
not performing anymore because when I knew
I used to perform at this level, it's hard
to accept that, "OK, I'm down here now."
And maybe that's not how I wanna be seen anymore.
[giggles]
>>FEMALE #4: Thank you.
>>FEMALE #5: Ask her?
OK.
I don't know.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: How old are you?
>>MALE #1: How old are you, Mia?
>>FEMALE #5: Four.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Four.
>>FEMALE #5: I'm really four.
>>FEMALE #6: When are you planning on coming
out with another book?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Actually, I'm working
on book two right now--the follow-up to this
book about Poppy.
So, it'll be the same character.
And it's more of an international feel to
the book.
And it will be released early March of 2012.
>>FEMALE #5: Oh, nice.
[laughter]
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Thank you.
Make sure you tell your Mommy you wanna see
the book, too.
>>FEMALE #5: Yeah.
OK.
>>Female Presenter: While the mic goes around,
I wanted to ask you who are some of your favorite
skaters?
>>FEMALE #5: Excuse me.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: The current competitors.
I think my favorite skaters right now are,
which I, it would've surprised me ten years
ago if you asked me this, they're actually
ice dancers--Meryl Davis and Charlie White.
They're the US National Champions.
Actually, just recently won the World Championships
last March.
So, they're just incredible, fresh, and gorgeous
on the ice.
And I think ice dancing has entered a new
era and I don't know.
I really like it.
I think they've done a great job representing
the sport.
>>FEMALE #7: Yeah, so I'm from Fremont, too.
[laughter]
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Yeah!
Wow, there's a lot.
>>FEMALE #7: And my daughter loves the Dreamland
playground, which I think is designed by you.
The Dreamland.
I think it's--.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Oh, at Central Park?
>>FEMALE #7: Yeah, at Central Park.
I forgot exactly what's the name of it, but
she loves it.
It's really unique playground from any other
place else.
So, thank you very much.
[laughs]
And what brings you to design such nice a
playground and it is very unique and different
from other places.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: OK, yeah.
She's talking about--.
We, my foundation, built an Always Dream Play
Park, which is in Central Park in Fremont
at Lake Elizabeth.
And it's one of the few of its kind in the
Bay Area.
it's all-abilities playground.
Another labor of love for our foundation.
It was something four, five years in the making
from concept.
We were working with a lot of children with
disabilities.
We actually did a summer camp in Hawaii with
kids with disabilities.
And after the four days, from the children
to the counselors to our board members, we
were all just transformed and wanted to do
something that was more permanent and serving
than the four days.
So, I had heard about these types of playgrounds
and we researched it.
We found the right architect, actually based
in Berkeley, and came up with the designs
and ultimately tried to raise the funding.
So, Fremont was a great partner.
They're obviously my home town, so they welcomed
this idea.
And so, we created this playground where kids
of all abilities can play side by side.
And it's accessible.
It's fun, even children with sensory issues
can find quiet spots to find solace in.
And then we're across the street from the
California School of the Deaf and Blind, so
a couple of things on the playground cater
to that as well.
So, yeah.
I don't know.
It was I think the biggest capital project
that we had ever taken on, but obviously one
of the most rewarding as well.
>>Female Presenter: Any other questions from
the audience?
>>FEMALE #8: Thank you for coming.
Sort of on the theme of dreaming big I guess,
so I've always wanted to write children's
books as well.
And I was just curious if you have any advice
for someone who hasn't started or doesn't
even really know how to start.
Any thought?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Yeah.
I mean, I think the most important thing is
come up with your concept first.
Like, what you want to accomplish in the story.
And that's what I came up with here.
I said I want someone positive.
I wanna leave a great message.
I want kids to know that it takes work and
failure to sometimes accomplish your dreams.
You don't necessarily have to win, but it's
more about giving it your best.
So it's finding that concept and putting those
together and then finding the character that
you want to be the one to express these things.
And then just writing it.
I don't know.
It's just jotting down.
I mean, I just did it on paper.
And the second book, too.
I wrote on paper and I'm scratching out and
throwing them away.
Just the old-fashioned way.
And when I finally got a manuscript that I
thought was presentable, then, well with the
first one turned it in and my book agent shopped
it around.
>>FEMALE #8: And did you already have a relationship
with the illustrator or did you--?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: No.
That came after the publisher came in.
They had an idea of what they wanted.
So, they introduced me to Tim via email.
I've never met him, actually.
[giggles] But everything was done through
approvals of sketches he turned in.
And I was just really lucky that I really
liked what he did.
>>FEMALE #8: Thank you.
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: You're welcome.
Right in front.
>>FEMALE #9: Can you talk a little bit about
your experience on "Dancing With the Stars?"
>>Female Presenter: The question was about
"Dancing With the Stars."
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Lots of fun.
I mean, what can you say?
[giggles]You watch the show and you can tell
everyone's having a lot of fun on it.
But I think the surprising thing for me was
that it was not so physically demanding, but
emotionally, mentally demanding as well.
I think the first few weeks you're just on
a high and you're like, "OK, I wasn't eliminated
first.
This is great."
[laughter]
"I'm still on the show."
And then it slowly becomes harder and harder
and there's more pressure and they're expecting
more of you.
But it was so much fun.
I had a great partner.
Mark Ballas was my professional partner.
Just talented beyond not only a dancer, but
his first passion is music.
So, he writes and composes and performs his
own music as well.
So, just a great group of people.
It kind of parallels the skating world a little
bit--the dance world--as far as the performing
side and the characters within it.
[giggles]
But it's a great show.
I think they know what they're doing, obviously.
The success of it is so big.
But it was an honor to actually be asked to
be on the show.
>>FEMALE #9: Just a follow up.
So, in tying in with your talk about dreaming
big, did you go into that competition thinking,
"I'm gonna get that mirror ball."
Or just.
Sorry.
What was your motivation?
[laughter]
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: My motivation?
My motivation was really just learning how
to ballroom dance.
'Cause I didn't wanna do the show because
having been a fan of the show, sitting around
with my girlfriends and ripping on all the
contestants--
[laughter]
I was like, "Oh, I don't wanna put myself
out there like that."
But when I looked past that, I was like, "OK."
I've always wanted to learn how to dance and
this type of dancing was so different from
anything else I have ever done.
I said, "OK.
Just let's give it a shot."
So, I don't know.
I just went for it.
[giggles]
>>Female Presenter: Anyone else?
>>FEMALE #10: Hey Kristi.
Thanks for coming.
Me and my sister we're also from Fremont.
[laughter]
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Fremont hands go up.
How many people are there from Fremont?
Oh my goodness.
Look at that.
Woo!
MSJ, any other MSJ?
All right.
[laughter]
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #11: Just out of
curiosity, how come you chose a pig for the
main character?
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: Oh, why a pig for the
I've always been a pig person.
I'm actually born Year of the Pig.
Oh, yeah.
And my idol was a pig growing up--Miss Piggy.
[laughter]
My parents used to call me "Pigpen" 'cause
I was always such a mess when I was a little
kid.
I don't know.
I've just always loved pigs.
I collected pigs.
A lot of my good luck stuffed animals were
pigs.
So, when I decided not to have a little girl
as the main character, the pig was my first
choice.
And I thought a pig would present its own
challenges as far as being a skater.
[laughter]
Anyone else?
>>Female Presenter: OK.
So, thank you so much, Kristi, for joining
us today.
I think it was a real pleasure for all of
[applause]
>>Kristi Yamaguchi: I just wanna say thank
you to Google for having me here today.
It was fun to meet all of you and connect
with my Fremont people.
[laughter]
I mean, I'm obviously a big fan of Google
and so it's an honor to be here, see your
campus, be invited in and to share just a
little bit of what I've done with all of you.
So, thank you so much and look forward to
maybe chatting with you guys later.
[chuckles]
[applause]